so we're making all these videos for you
guys about how to get cool shots and how
to make your footage look good now we
have vfx that's a great way to do it
color grading that's another really good
way to do it but one thing we haven't
talked about is camera movement that is
easily one of the best ways to make your
shot look cool now
when i mean camera movement i'm talking
about that cool cinematic stuff that you
usually associate with big budget movies
usually
what that entails is
they take their cameras
and they put it on a crane and the crane
goes up 50 feet and swoops down all nice
and smooth or uh they take it and they
put on like a little track called a
dolly track which allows the camera to
perfectly move side to side and
basically all these motions you're
seeing are it's stuff that's impossible
to do with your own hands and that's why
it looks so cool you're seeing angles
that typically you don't see in day to
day life plus
they are rock solid there's no shake
there's no handheld motion in it and
there's no like recognizing that it's
actually just a guy holding the camera
there you know it's it's it's larger
than life and i'm going to show you guys
how to do that today with
the warp stabilization filter so there's
a lot of ways to stabilize your footage
when you're just shooting handheld a lot
of lenses have actually stabilization
built in and you'll usually see a little
switch but that only corrects for like
little handheld motion but that's not
gonna help you for like big swooping
shots and stuff like that so i'm gonna
give you guys the big list of do's and
don'ts when you're shooting with uh warp
stabilization in mind usually long
steady motions work best with the
program um that means you know taking
the camera and going over like 30 feet
with it but just generally keeping it in
the same position or
for that matter just you know keeping
the angle or the line just very smooth
steady long simple you don't want to be
sitting there like going around going
through curved hallways spinning the
camera around um that really doesn't
work with the software so that's the
only limitation you have handheld
walking forwards just trying to get a
smooth shot pushing in on a subject
first step you want to do here is you
want to make sure that you're always
framing out
a little wider than you think you're
going to have to because the first thing
that warp stabilization does to any
footage is it crops it in because it
needs all the extra room on the outside
to kind of compensate i'm going to want
to take my shutter speed and crank that
up a little bit about 1 over
1 over 200 for this shot and what that's
going to do it's going to reduce the
motion blur in the shot making the shot
a lot easier to track and stabilize
later because there's no motion blur not
to mention you can always add in motion
blur later if you really want it and
going
oh yeah
cool you'll also notice the speed i was
going at was actually pretty slow and
that's because of just simply the 3d
shake involved with that if you want to
do it a lot faster it's actually pretty
easy to just hop on a pair of wheels
such as like a scooter skateboard even a
pair of heelies and essentially get
those shots at a lot higher speeds i'm
going to show you guys one of these
moves right now i'm going to go all the
way up and down the hallway and get one
sweet super fast shot going down it
nice
so it's already pretty smooth but the
warp stabilization takes out all those
little bumps so those were forward and
backwards movements those are pretty
simple uh sometimes you want to do more
complex ones though such as like side to
side movements uh or like orbiting
around subjects and usually the biggest
thing you have to look out for when
doing these types of shots though is the
difference between the foreground and
the background objects the reason this
makes it harder is because when you have
stuff at such great distances from each
other the slightest movement you'll make
will create a huge difference in motion
between the objects and it's a lot
harder to correct for that so when
shooting those shots um and dealing with
foreground objects there's two solutions
you can really do is you can move back a
little farther
just to get everything pushed back and
recessed into the space you're working
in or you can just move in front of them
just cut them out of the shot completely
and that'll definitely solve all your
problems also there's one other thing
that's really dangerous to have in your
shot and that is natural lens flares
because when filming the flare the
motion of it is relative to how you're
actually moving the camera around so
when you stabilize the footage rather
than having a smooth flare suddenly it's
going to be all wobbly and shaking
around like it was in your original
footage now that i've finally filmed all
my footage i'm going to bring it back
onto my computer and you can use warp
stabilizer in either adobe cs 5.5 cs6
and now
adobe premiere cs6 as well really handy
all you got to do go to your effect
tab go to your distort tab and apply
warp stabilizer now right when you apply
it it's going to start analyzing the
footage so you have to wait a little bit
the basic settings you got to know when
looking at your footage are the
following at the top you see a tab that
says smooth motion you also see
no motion if you open it up smooth
motion will give you exactly what it
tells you smooth motion no motion is
really good for when you're just trying
to stabilize a handheld shot generally
you're not moving around it's just
correcting for the shakiness of the shot
that'll stabilize it and lock it off and
it's great so the next one down is
smoothness and by default it's set to 50
percent if you slide it to zero percent
it will turn off smoothness completely
and you'll be left with your raw footage
if you set it to 100 it's just going to
go crazy and your footage might start
looking a little bit weird you might
have to experiment the next one down
from that you see method by default it's
set to subspace warp
you can go through a whole bunch of
options here generally you only use
subspace warp and position scale
rotation the difference between the two
is that subspace warp will actually
warp the edges of your footage to
correct for the perspective that your uh
camera is shifting around in so it
actually alters the footage uh position
scale and rotation what that does is
that attempts to correct your footage
all by using just default motion such as
you know sliding it around rotating it
scaling it it's not actually distorting
the footage at all so depending on the
result you're trying to get and the shot
you're trying to work with
one might be better over the other but
generally subspace warp does the job but
the other one that can possibly come in
handy is the stabilized and synthesized
edges and what that does is that
actually will compensate for the
automatic scaling effects being applied
to your footage and actually try and
rebuild the outside of your frame the
synthesized edges though it takes a lot
of rendering time and generally it's
more time than it's worth so you know a
good range for your scale to be set at
is anywhere between 100 and i'd say
about 120 percent for your footage if
you start pushing it any further than
that
you're going to start seeing some
serious like degradation of the footage
and it's not going to look that good so
if your shot's going past that you might
want to take your smoothness down a
little bit here's also a problem that we
didn't run into but you guys might so
now let's say you're shooting a shot and
it's going great and then someone kind
of walks into the side of the frame and
comes back out and when you come in the
track it it throws your whole track off
because suddenly it pushes the frame in
because you have this random object just
blocking your footage now you can
actually fix that pretty easily by using
masking and what you want to do is
basically just select the mat around the
good areas to track and stabilize and
pre-compose that so that when you apply
the filter it will only be looking at
that one area and all the messy stuff
that you don't want to stabilize it'll
just be completely ignored
so i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and learned something from it if you
have any questions about this feel free
to tweet at us
or maybe uh you can read the manual it's
on the internet
whatever works
you